all right Lock and Load you guys let's
do it you got you got notes oh come on
I'm talking to the greatest living
director I gotta you're supposed to be
talking well I also have some anecdotes
about the weather in case
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent hey come on everybody move on
out I feel whenever I'm on a set I'm
just like I'm not directing this you
could direct it let's get a crane let's
get
a first time I saw him was in um a Lucas
film I call me by your name yeah and so
you know and I a great admire of Luca
and I love the picture I always talk
about um performances but they aren't
really they're like behavioral where you
don't see the acting you know what I
mean yes and so um I connected there and
I saw Dune
you know which I enjoyed and I started
to see a sense of rage you know and then
they said they Chanel asked me to do
this spot for
Blue uh which you had already done I had
done years ago right yeah had the first
one they said they had this young
gentleman named Timothy shalamay and I
said ah that one I know and we had some
kind of a dinner and talk Etc we had a
plan for the I guess you call it a
commercial I don't know what it is it's
a little narrative I it's not
provocative of other commercials and
perfume commercials in a good way in a
good way I think it's somewhat different
than that and and so it's it's a story
anyway um but how to break it through
you know my latest film was over 3
hours this 60 seconds and it's so Mar
it's only only 60 seconds the thing
about 60 seconds is it's harder
condensed condensed and every frame
counts every frame you know I know we're
talking digital but there's still frames
in digital mhm but I mean one frame more
two frame that's the way we're editing
this thing add two frames take away a
frame you know ju to position of images
all the sort of thing so it's not an a
fcil way of working it's actually I find
these much more intense and it's a
they're
real um workouts more challenging yeah
more challenging The Narrative itself
was about the film actor and being on
the road and um one of the things we
referred to was the great uh short film
by Federico felini Toby damit Toby damit
yeah and I showed it to you and uh I
said let's capture some of that feeling
you know that's one of my favorite
interactions with you is you said you've
seen Toby damn it right and I thought
this felini this your felini short no I
haven't but I quickly quickly got onto
it with that as an inspiration we we uh
came up with the story somehow but
developed into a kind of story and how
that happened I'm not quite sure no but
it's I I'm so grateful I felt but I love
I felt so honored that you brought uh
because um this didn't feel like a
commercial and I guess the fear as an
actor that's why I was so excited that
you agreed to do it too is that you know
you don't have to feel you know whatever
like a product I know this was a total
dream total short film what I walked
away with the most we haven't even
gotten a chance to speak about it but I
was just so shocked about how
unprecidented detail it was just so
fascinating when filmmakers started out
and I broke a lot of young filmmakers
there enormously precious and maybe
plotting sometimes here we were just
like going you know well it was planned
beforehand yeah to fly like that well
not to fly like that but I was glad it
flew yeah but no the the shots were
designed or at least the I like to call
it like a philosophy of a shot should
this be a moving shot at all right or
should it be static and if it's static
what the hell size are you in the frame
right is it from the waist up so that
was all basically plan yeah I mean I
mean then when you get into the like
they're looking out the window when you
see the uh uh the billboard the
billboard I know you're going to walk
towards camera but where do you stop um
I didn't know there was a shot list
basically I have it myself do you always
work like that basically or not well
back fures yes back in uh when I started
doing uh my first films I would draw
everything wow that sounds time
intensive yeah well I was by myself
anyway I was always by myself nobody
wanted to be that's that's another story
another I was always in a room by myself
taxi driver was literally there
literally across the street designed the
whole picture and Drew all the pictures
right across the street at the St
Bridges hotel in that out that window I
spent a lot of time doing that because
first of all I like the idea of how to
tell a story with pictures right but it
also because it was so low budget MH I
had to really have a plan have a plan so
that it could be changed had you had an
experience where you didn't have a plan
that ined yes later on I tried I tried
another film but it I seemed to work
better with a plan really do it's like
showing up memorized or showing up un
memorized
yes yes yes probably deal with a lot of
people that are un memorized no it's
true but you memorize is one thing
knowing it's another right yeah as long
as you know exactly as long as you know
it you know you could start fooling
around with stuff and but I tried a
different experiment once and it didn't
work for me but over the years the
drawings became notes and little
drawings in the margins of the of the
script or let's say in good fellow
actually was put into the script how
silic shot shot lists or or that the
actors would go off of in some way or no
no as long as I had actors who could if
I had a specific shot I wanted to get
which was complicated as long as he or
she would be able to behave uh
unencumbered in the frame you know if
I'm asking them to look backwards and
walk forwards at the same time and that
I found that to be a problem then I may
have adjusted the shot you right right
depend on what's more important uh their
faces and what they're doing or this
particular move to the left or right but
it's amazing and after thr hours and
Good Fellas there's shots sometimes that
pushing rapidly on someone and they're
doing something very natural
behaviorally obviously dairo is one of
the greatest ever but you'll be a
camera's flying at him and he's like
picking his teeth or something he's not
Disturbed and uh that's why I was so
seriously inspired working with you is
that it was so
Moon you saw I mean in certain cases you
just hold the camera don't move right
now I was shocked with Killers too it's
very engaging I'm shocked only because
of the the runtime but it's your grip
the entire time that was our big
gambling it's amazing U pacing wise all
those characters feel out of that era
Leo most of all I know I tell you well
you know what it's like you're in a
place like that you learn to live in it
yeah and you become part of it yeah and
I mean yeah it was a long shoot but a
lot of my pictures has lately have been
long right that's why I wanted to do
this I wanted to change the style right
away I had to freshen up right right I
had to change it doesn't mean go faster
I had to think differently you know to
force myself to think differently no I
loved it was lean it was muscular and it
was like way more running gun than I
ever would have thought I wanted to be
free and open yeah it was constructed as
I say and designed right but yeah but
there's room to play yeah that's what I
loved um from my perspective sometimes
Direction can be really explicit and
then when something's really explicit
it's quite hard to get to I can't
imagine how how you do it yeah because
you kind of lose your mind you know but
when and I felt you nudging which is
really the best because if you're
getting sort of gently and then if you
don't get there I felt that too if I was
like it's not going to work it
we're going to go do something else do
something else well because but you see
the nature of this spot lent itself to
that because of um uh the spontaneity of
the show let's say or the backstage
chaos you know look being specific and
blocking specifically it's another way
of artistic expression right you know
and there are times when I have to do it
right you know but this particular story
didn't need that yes you know I I think
we we hit we hit the pacing right
getting in the the van was hard when we
hit you with the camera but that was
used that's when I was laughing the
first time I saw this SP CU I thought
wow this is again
unprecipitated you look up you know it
kind of indicates the audience that what
you're going to see for the next minute
minute and a half whatever it is is
something very different and special I
shot a movie in New York 7 years ago on
the streets whatever and it was so
wonderful to to rap and then walk home
feels more like a creative exercise I
guess well the city has the and they
always use the cliche of the energy but
it does have the energy right it simply
does because everybody's on top of each
other right I mean look at it all the
buildings on top of each it's different
from La La is spread out you get the car
back in 1971 when when I learned to
drive I had to learn to drive out there
it was wonderful it's made for cars yeah
you know and you just turn the music up
your uh your Edge rots out there
though yeah it tended to but luckily I
was able to do films like taxi driver
and then right mainly because they saw
main streets and they wanted to Nero and
myself together on that film but it was
a different New York oh that was the New
York of um you know Ford to City Dro
Dead We shot in the summer of 76 it was
the most apparently the most violent no
well violent yes but you see for me
violence here is always the same I I I I
grew up here I I'm always walking in the
street a certain way or I know not yeah
he was checking your shoulder so the
thing about it is now I I I just know I
could see a person coming down that may
not because I grew up downtown on the in
a rough area L side when the bowy was
the bowy and it was pretty scary growing
up as a kid but um what had happened was
that the city was going to go bankrupt
and they asked the uh from my long story
short they asked for federal the bronc
is on fire Insurance scheme yeah yeah it
was a buildings were collapsing that was
that famous building that collapsed uh
that we put in vinyl it was uh apparent
the lowest e that the city has ever been
in was then was that mid when we were sh
perfect cinematic background yeah but
for me it was normal right I was used to
that I grew up in Hell's Kitchen um and
uh Hell's Kitchen changed a lot from
when I was growing up cuz when I was
growing up it was still a little bit on
the edge in the Port Authority Bus
Terminal and that the port Authority's
kept its Edge by Nature I guess yeah it
has I mean the neighborhood is much
dressed up come up a bit but the Port
Authority was I used to use that a lot I
was living in New Jersey actually been
in the mid-60s it was very cheap to live
in Union City or Jersey City and I
coming in and out of that Port Authority
Bus Terminal what I saw in there yeah in
the' 60s my God it was horrifying right
the only places I think probably in
Alphabet City still has a sense of uh
the old tenaments that I grew up in
that's what was weird working on this
commercial too is is uh it's not tropes
but so much of the iconicism of New York
has stemmed from your work so it's
bizarre to all of a sudden be you know
well the only thing is like when we when
you're down in the uh in the street in
SoHo that you're walking along at the
end of the uh when I was growing up that
street is where you went to steal hubc
caps and now it's uh and also other
things yeah so I I got that I stole the
H and I was with guys you know kids now
it's like being in um Province toown
Connecticut I guess I never was there
but it's fancy as hell yeah yeah I love
in Taxi Driver haven't just watched it
again I feel like you see so many things
about moody or people on the edge
watching it again the opening shots are
like super beautiful and Serene and the
music's playing and it's not lecturing
the movie is not lecturing you and
telling no I just saw the city that way
all the time one of my favorite things
in the city is the steam coming up out
of the street M and so I had to have the
car go through the steam that opening
shine yeah yeah I had to and I was done
on 22nd Street somewhere late at night
that was criticized at one point by
certain snobby critics saying and that's
the level of the metaphor of the film
film hell you know cab is coming from
hell I said no that's New York it's it's
the steam in the streets it is what it
is and when you see things come through
that steam that way you could think of
if you want you could think of The
Inferno you could think of paradise
right you don't know right you know um
it's a beauty of the city late at night
that way when you just pipes of smoke
coming up all the way up second and
third Avenue oh man yeah absolutely
beautiful and the red lights the tail
lights of the cars it was always raining
too that that summer you guys got
it was always raining finally we were
waiting for the rain and we started to
go 2 or 3 days over schedule and they
were really mad at us the studio was
screaming and I got in a lot of trouble
because I'm going to pull the plug on
the picture and so I said I we're
shooting in the ring so it's not going
to
match we'll have to figure out how to
well we better shoot fast then now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah get it done get it
done I still go back to basics you know
right normal lens long lens wide angle
lens right and then from there you could
go infinite right you know and so uh
movement or no movement movement of the
frame or movement of the camera in the
frame because a pan is different from a
track right right so I stay with those
Basics and then if there are new things
that that could be implemented in there
using focal length in a certain way but
I do find that um after all these years
uh and with all the new technology there
are more choices and it's kind of good
way except that more than two3 of those
choices you don't need to make right cuz
end up wasting time or something it's
wasting time yeah so it always goes down
to the basic the basic as an actor and
as a director what do you want to say
right and what's in the way something's
in the way what the hell is it is it
technology or is somebody you know in
front of you and you're trying to do
something and they're distracting you
it's it's that it's that simple right
and now with there's a few filmmakers
that have a command of both right yeah
yeah it's not get sucked into just The
Cutting Edge well I think a lot lot of
those filmmakers are recent in because
they they grew up with the technology I
did not it's another generation yeah
it's going to be interesting what you
guys do well that's why I'm and I don't
want to be cynical and I I don't want to
take myself out of being a member of my
generation as I have in the past but um
I just think uh boredom is a good thing
and the way I was intensely bored
growing up and had to read books or if I
could get my hands on a movie at my
grandma's house you cherish that movie
and with too much information too much
access you know what I mean you can't
you're not going to well was a similar
what you're talking about boredom in a
sense because of um in my case when I
was 3 years old 1945 I contracted asthma
and my parents working class they were
not they didn't have books in the house
and that sort of thing they would just
take me to the movies a lot or let me
eventually go by myself to the movies
and I had this little tiny area in the
apartment before everybody came back
from work wow then I to learn how to
read novels and this priest was a
interesting guy father prip was the one
who gave us Graham green and James Joyce
and that sort of about for 13 or 14
right and it started to read that was a
whole issue right you know but I think
uh it was peace meal in some way yeah
yeah but what happens is that he old
take the horse to water you know and if
the horse
drinks you know so that I had had a
couple of people who were doing that for
me and we were sustaining ourselves we
were continuing we took advantage of
those uh suggestions and guidance and it
wasn't always friendly these were tough
guys but they weren't telling you what
to think or what was good they were kind
of giving you the keys in some way
giving you a basis of morality too right
and somebody pointed out said like in
killers of the flower moon or number
number of the films I made where the
level of corruption is so deep because
it's not the the society is not rooted
in in Morality or any kind of
spirituality that's what human nature
might be that without that guidance or
without that even
dialogue uh between people about
morality and spirituality becomes it
becomes pure corruption right I mean if
I you know in the the movie it because
the Native Americans don't understand
the value of money if I you know charge
you a dollar for this glass of water
they pay it and then they realize you
realize they don't really understand
paper money or anything like that
they're rich but they don't know why um
and they don't know they don't know what
money is so when they come in again I'm
going to say it's $10 and they pay it
right so I'm going to say next time $25
I'll keep 15 meantime we're friends we
take care of each other and just like
you know you got the money anyway I
don't I have to work for the money
you're not I mean but that's an
interesting moral issue MH if it's only
a dollar charge a dollar and so that's
the interesting thing about how we could
become complicit in um Al absolutely
genocide yeah and a genocide not told
about really I I wasn't educated on it
but the movie is still very spiritual
though like a almost all your it is I
think it is I think it is a spiritual
core to it it's in how corruption just
uh infiltrates every aspect of your life
and you could learn to live with it
because you don't react against it you
don't speak up that's what's so great
about the Leo character and it you know
without giving anything away this guy's
a complicated figure to say the least
but it's handled so delicately you don't
feel that you're taking them uh you know
you're not instructing the viewer how to
feel either way no no no no no no not at
all not at all like uh in the case of uh
Wolf of Wall Street for example I only
learned the other day from uh an
interviewer who said you're not aware of
the war of Wolf of Wall Street I said
what are you talking about said well
there was a big screening at paramont
the picture and the for the critics in
New York apparently I was told this
there were two camps one camp that love
the picture in the other camp that was
Furious saying I didn't take a moral
stand on Jordan Belford and one of the
critics from the other group that liked
the picture said do you really need
Martin SC sayi to tell you that that's
wrong right that's well said it's well
said you really need him to tell you
that drunk well said he knows a
drunk is that moralistic attitude bore
you a little bit now or no well it's
beyond boring I think you know it's
always been around I mean well because
American's a Puritan country well it
says it is MH right well that's what's
confusing to me as a young person is but
there's a difference there's a
difference between religion and
spirituality okay and religion could
could taken the taken the wrong way
could become something that is
restricting
and becomes intolerable and becomes
judgmental judgmental key word there
yeah yeah so you have a big problem good
example is Killers the flower Moon yeah
there were all Europeans who were
Protestants right you know I'm not
condemning Protestants I'm just saying
that was the um the moral code they had
a morality uh you know when a guy like
Bill hail played by dairo who says I
love these oage people and he's killing
them but he does love them
now what is that it's fantastic because
you don't feel them there's no music cue
that made that says this guy's evil you
know no it's it's he's just going to do
what he's going to do but that that's
the the thing I think uh ultimately
about concentration for younger people
and taking the time not just to make a
movie to become famous that's good too
if you can yeah but but I think
ultimately if you have something to say
if you're really burning and not just
the party line yes exactly because the
most important things are things that
are new and fresh point away forward
point you to how people are feeling it's
harder to no now there's great there's
less mainstreaming of things now I think
things are a little more I was going to
say the other night we were at this big
event I that people were talking about
that the news is uh different now and
this and I said look back when I was
growing up there was CBS NBC ABC it's
gone right I said in effect the
mainstream is going does that shock you
having been so repr representative of
your generation to feel now like what
the hell am I looking at kind of thing
or no um but you're so young in spirit I
mean that I'm not just saying that smoke
than no no that that's nice but I I I
like keeping that youth and like keeping
an open mind but an open mind means less
restrictions and these days um for good
reason and for good intent there is a
great deal of a closing of the Mind
Right kill Killers walks that line
incredibly because tells us story of a
moral Injustice basic more than a moral
Injustice a human Injustice but you
still have characters that are
wonderfully complicated and yeah yeah
and that's that's that's hard to achieve
well because because there isn't such it
isn't as simple as suddenly you go into
a world it's all morally injust and
everybody's very serious and you they're
all villains no it's the guy next to you
it's you even Catholicism was confession
you have to examination of conscience or
ma it was Ma self-criticism you know
what I mean right but not to be afraid
to to to to criticize yourself right um
and don't come don't become cowed by
what other people think right and what
they want you to think I should say
right do you feel like the story around
your life and your work you know uh
impacted the kind of movies you were
making I don't know the story of my life
was I guess Round Up in the movies the
mid '70s that was a little rough period
pretty rough period till about 78 7678
were pretty tough and came out of it at
the end of 78 mhm I just embraced myself
from where I came from and did this film
that janir really wanted me to make over
the years but I had resisted and that
was Raging Bull I think I read that you
hadn't wanted to do it at first well for
many different reasons he saw it sooner
than I did he knew it was me he knew it
was in me the Jak Lama of character that
we were making and so then I felt
comfortable and I realized oh I know you
didn't see at first you no I was blind
because you thought you didn't relate to
it or uh it was first of all we hadn't
we hadn't really Consolidated the script
like Mar it's a huge story yeah and the
last 30 minutes or a different movie in
an amazing way yeah but there were
different things the the relationship
with dairo was changing too cuz of his
stardom yeah and and other things do you
want to work again with with him you
know what I'm saying I had to think
about that well some of the best
collaborations happen with you know yeah
yeah yeah but we went through that
period and we came out the other side
and was Raging Bull right there you go
so then we did it again and K comedy
then I wanted to go off into Last
Temptation Of Christ to other films that
I want to gangs in New York things like
that and uh ultimately when I say
embraced where I came from Raging Bull
was uh you know it's the' 70s and where
I came from people were still alive mhm
my parents were still living down in the
tenament MH um a lot of the stories I
was putting in my movies had elements of
Truth in them mhm a lot of people down
there were still alive names you
couldn't mention so yes you're there's a
sensitivity around these so I you know I
was in LA I had long hair I had cowboy
clothes I love I saw picture you at the
Film Festival recently and I I something
already I met yeah yeah so so no what
happened I had to grow the beard because
I looked so young everybody was laughing
you know they thought it was 12 years I
said no no okay so I grew a beard but
what I'm getting at is that uh I
couldn't really talk too much or Embrace
too much my background but by the time I
had did raing B said the hell with it
right and I went back and my mother and
father in the film and we just started
using your mom she in it y was it simp
like a like simply a respectful fear or
more than that it was a caution it was
caution yes yes no no a lot of people
were still alive yeah there before the
Little Italy became the Little Italy
that it is now right it was a closed
Society right no names mentioned ever
right it's nice when you come back with
the director there a there's a dialogue
there's a rapport also on the acting
side you feel like oh this guy this
person really likes me CU I'm I'm back
again yeah exactly me out yeah exactly
it gives you confidence but you've done
that I mean legendarily with dairo and
DiCaprio yeah and we'll do Chanel
commercials every three yes exactly no
but with them though it's a different
thing because dairo knew me from low E
side when we were 16 years old so he
knew the people I grew up with right
still does uh so a few of them left he
was on with another group uh up on
kenmir street we were on uh Prince and
and hon okay Prince and hon Street
Elizabeth M mulber every now and then we
met in these after hour bars late at
night respectful and always very very
nice to each other some of the guys he
was with were I didn't like I miss might
I'm talk yeah myself and a couple of my
friends we the stay guys stay was he
already acting I couldn't tell I don't
think so I lost track of him is what
happened and because Brian dep had been
working with dairo and high mom wow and
so they said you got to meet him and and
after the dinner was over we were
sitting in another room and and he
looked at me he says uh you used to hang
out with ctie right and Joe
morale and you're with the remember ALB
eyes I said yeah he said I'm Bobby I
said Bobby you mean Bobby from K he says
yeah wow I said him realize and that's
how we came back together linked my God
and now you live five blocks from each
other or whatever I don't know he seems
to be around the corner yeah you see I
can't tell in between rols he doesn't
look he looks Anonymous I have no idea
who he is he could be right next to me
he's at B&B Bagels on the line behind
you something yeah yeah you don't know
what's going on I mean one night we had
dinner with Michael Powell the Great
British director uh we preparing for
Raging Bull he wanted to ask him
questions about gaining weight there's a
sequence that Powell does in this film
Kel blimp I said well we'll meet Bob
tonight at dinner and there was a
apartment I had on uh 57 Street and
we're up there eating and Bob's next to
him and everything's fine and after the
main course before dessert he said I
understand dairo will be coming tonight
I said he's right next to you oh my God
he had realized the whole time because
he's very quiet and anous Anonymous you
feel feel it in his work you feel
someone that's not vain basically I know
that's the key because Hey listen if the
shot plays best on my back and on
somebody else's face play it right
whereas other actors they need highlight
they need to look a certain way not
talking about me by the way he didn't
need any he didn't any um and with Leo
Leo just interesting 30 30-year
difference but he has similar
sensibility mhm and a curiosity mhm
curiosity is the key thing you know man
is it ever that's the biggest thing
there's a Bob Dylan quote from
Chronicles his book I might butcher it a
little bit but he says if your ability
to uh Inspire be curious or observed is
compromised in any way then your
creativity is compromised that's right
yeah and that's the danger of today too
yeah because what there's an answer to
everything yeah an answer and there's a
understandably a sensitivity mhm you
know which has to be balanced with art
somehow mhm because uh the art be free I
just read for taxi driver that there was
some like all the directors had come up
with some rule or something I'm going to
butcher this too but that to to be
moralistic to not put violence in movies
or something yeah I still got that I got
that oh my God I was I was shunned for
Good
Fellas now why Shun in certain Italian
restaurants it wouldn't let me in would
do you feel like over the years that
perception changed no it I mean look
violence is that in the ancient Greeks
violence usually took place
offstage and it was described
right messenger comes in says you should
see what happened right right right you
should see what they did to to you know
helus he was up there they they tore him
apart in the baket oh my God you know
also helps the fight budget and the St
budget yeah yeah but um but it was just
as scary and just as disturbing um
highly stylized I guess I've had this
kind of question about violence going
all the way back to main streets MH you
know but I grew up in a place that was
you know violence was form of expression
right and communication yeah yeah and it
was serious there was a difference
between a a friendly slap and a slap mhm
and that was up to you to determine you
could see that in Good Fellas when he
says you think I'm funny was that
scripted no yeah that wasn't scripted no
something something happened to Joe in
his
life and he told me and he said he got
himself out of it he got him by saying
he was on the yeah you're screwing with
me you're screwing with me guy said I
had you there you bastard I had you you
know and I said that's the story it
wasn't even the script we put it in that
reminds me when I was in Middle School
on 1008 in Amsterdam and uh I saw one of
my good friends Jordan the week before
someone said to him he got basically a
tussle in an argument with a guy and uh
he said to the guy you're so tough punch
me in the face and he leaned in and the
other guy was terrified he backed down
so you know a week later I was getting
hassled by some kids I leaned into the
guy said you so tough punch me in the
face and I got one of the few times in
my life I got punched so bad really
hurts that really one of the few times
in my life I got really rocked in the
face
it's good lesson though yeah no I I I I
found luckily I had the asthma because
they leave me alone they were some of
the toughest guys they would P fool you
around and get mad at you and then say
ah it's all right the kid's sick and
they would take yeah come here and they
would took care of me oh I love in the
uh in the in the spot when you say well
I'd be kinder to myself wait I haven't
seen I don't remember that this must be
the new version yeah we put that anyway
thank you thanks for let me chat like
this
thanks can we settle we're just getting
the last line right here and we're we're
ending hey you guys settled or what it
can't be that
bad are you guys just trying to get he's
good what are you
talking is that one a big deal this
kid sorry guys this be take two let's
see how sincere this is thanks again
thanks again for chatting about well
thank you thank you Timothy and uh I
guess I'll see you later right I'll see
you tonight okay we'll celebrate this
[Music]
terrific